[Music] it's that time again at Dancing with the Stars returns in just a few weeks and two sources confirm a to ET that mr. t will be one of the celebs hitting the ballroom invited me a source close to the show tell ZT producers have been trying to get the 18 star on the show for years quote you will be a great contestant this season if I could do the spring season I would love to do that et has also learned that Olympic gymnast Simone biles will join mr. t on the dance floor come March 20th we already knew a couple pros returning for season 24 max & peeta I'm definitely a little bit nervous but I'm very excited to get back you know I've definitely missed the dance floor and I haven't been able to you know defend my title with Nile so I want to get back out there